doing nothing that all sounds so
nice and I think if you
tell someone now you can have a lot of money
and you don't have to do anything then everyone would
say so wow awesome that's kind of my
dream but the reality is
different when you can't achieve it
neither do you and I think people
per se are not built in such a way that they are not made
happy by achieving nothing and that
is totally the case with me if you
do nothing no fitness or no
business then it is somehow too empty for
me normally would have to be here now  the
eurovision anthem will play like it did before the
eurovision song contest or before
bet that i as thomas
gottschal would say a warm welcome
dear viewers in germany
austria and switzerland today
is perhaps the most relevant
austrian digital founder
florian schwand once
set up runtastic later for a lot  Money and everything
sold with a lot of money
invested a lot found new things again he
believes very strongly in apps
but in a completely different way than people previously believed in apps
and why he sees what he
does with all his
wealth and potential
and his  all the options that he
tells us so today the roof podcast with
Flug Thunder let's go tomorrow
hello thanks for letting me be there so
2019 at the beginning of the year is really a
long time four years have you
enjoyed life since then I mean the company
became runtastic yes  sold quite well,
exactly, I think I also
enjoyed life before, but that was of course
characterized by having 250
employees. We also have a
day-to-day life, as you know, who
is very structured and very full, and now it
’s a bit more flexible, I have it for
better or for worse  reassigned a few packages
but it hasn't necessarily
become less work but I
actually always enjoyed
working and with hasseln, so to speak, there was
always something that was good let
the situation in again because in the
last few weeks it has happened more often in the podcast
people who  now
come to us for the second time or in general who
we are talking about who actually
de facto has the choice of what to do with
their lives because they
have sold a successful one because Christian
Vollmann is there artificially in the
episode with Florian always
talked about what  for ways you can go
the Andreas tümler who used to
earn a lot of money with five sales
then somehow makes a whiskey
distillery uh,
let's explain the situation a bit so it was
the sale of runtastic first
Axel Springer that you already have
earn a little money then the
company was sold again by Springer adidas you
can read I think
220 million was paid the
relevant shares belonged but then you got
out of there relatively quickly and then
you asked yourself okay what am I doing
in my life exactly now  it didn't
go that fast so we
founded it in 2009 then i told everything i did
n't get any money nobody really
believed austria german mentality
no i can go because who should
walk with a mobile phone go fast forward
hammer sold a part to axel springer
20.13 there have  we actually
already made good money the big exit
then in August 20 15 220 million the
biggest austrian exit and then
um and we were then but
i was also on board for three and a half years at
adidas there has its
extended management round go the
qualitative  Group was
also involved as the youngest member, the film
board also worked together because
we at Adidas, I think it was
a very nice acquisition, so it
worked really well. There was
a firewall, so we were
allowed to continue working relatively independently and
I also have a board
and with digital we were able to contribute a lot there
and then he came Kaspar rostet
also at Adidas and he also
supported it again digital first we
have to go e-commerce and we were
actually able to contribute a lot of know-how
it was an exciting journey but
you learn  then too, or at least
I don’t want to do tele business there in a large corporation
and then I
decided at the end of 2018 that was then somehow tested for almost ten years, then it’s better
to get ADAC then you open in the morning and
ask yourself what exactly then  if
you open ah then you do it like how
many do that take a break like 6 months
off that
worked mediocre at least a few months
worked where i was traveling a bit
more and and and but
of course we already started 20 13, so
to speak  also
to make business angel investments we had
tractive code dangers dad at that time so there were
always projects next door test yourself
and you probably
couldn’t let go completely and took some
time off again but you have to
be honest now that
nothing  doing it all sounds so nice and
I think if you now tell someone you
can have a lot of money and you do
n't have to do anything then everyone would say so wow
cool that's kind of my dream but
the reality is different if you
don't achieve something like that
neither do you and I believe that people
per se are not built in such a way that they are not made
happy by achieving nothing and that
is totally the case with me if
you have nothing, you have no fitness or no
business then it is somehow too empty for
me and then that is attractive  do you have
that in life right now they were
a podcast a few years ago even yesterday so that
's the main reason, so to speak, that's a company that
's already on the way to becoming a unicorn, really, really dirty, the Michael [ __ ] from there,
someone was there  you Philipp, michi
somehow has an idea of
becoming self-employed I was
at Mountain View at the time or we
met
we kind of started it together
they were then
made subtenants at runtastic is
my founding colleagues and we were the
first investors and a bit of
co-founders  also because it
was similar GPS tracking and such technology, but
you have to say that from then on,
Michael really took over
the helm and two other Michaels and Wolfgang
took over and did a mega job,
we are
probably around 100 million euros this year
in Bookings we are now going to reach
the one million subscriber limit this year too
the company makesprecise tractive makes GPS
tracking for dogs and cats that means
you put a little dirt on the
collar and then you find the
dog it’s very much about safety and
meanwhile  but also a lot about
health data one would like to believe
whether the animals are vital how much does
the dog scratch itself needs a veterinarian and
so you can’t just
solve it with your apple tag a good
question because many have said apple
is coming now apple was too  a good
nebulizer again for us because Apple
only worked when there were
other smartphones around and
when the dog now runs into the forest
or in the barn or somewhere in the city
it works very
imprecisely we really have GPS tracking
inside  we have Bluetooth in there
we can track it very precisely and
as I said movement data
vitality data and and there is a lot more
to it and you also have to understand Philipp
the pet industry it is
not that sensitive at all you give everything for
your dog for your cat you can do one
make good deals we also have a great
partnership here with martin rüttner
who is on tv a lot so the
puppies come and so it's a
huge business we sell online
the device only costs 50 € and then a subscription for like 5
€ a month and as i said  soon a
million subscribers and large
participants but still a good
single-digit percentage sign and everything is
good so hopefully again in the
next few years or were always there
is still a lot possible yes it is
definitely for that that it was
the second founding, so to speak, then it was
mega  successful but that makes
the management unbelievable again
in any case yes yes well that's
already it was the last evaluation we
did a round but we
had such small investments at the beginning
but in truth we think we have a round
after nine years  I've now
made it to 35 million that was
two years ago and that's public, so can
I say it too? I think it was
rated 231 and million for that
's really a great success for
an app or for a company
that  yes, what really makes it very close to
track dogs and cats somehow,
but okay, export exactly and you
mustn't forget it's still
my game hardware, you have to accommodate almost all the
functionalities of a mobile phone GPS GSM,
the antenna in a small space,
bring down the power,
WLAN modules, that sounds  it's that simple but
then many would do it too it's
really a hardware business and it's
really that he has ten people sitting in
the firmware engineer and and and and
so it's more complex than it is often in life
as so often in life than you think
That means you already
leaned into the company a bit, so at the beginning
we just helped out, we
had the producers
and so we used the same
producers at the beginning because we
had the connections in Hong Kong,
especially at the beginning it was just like that
a bit faster start for
tractive Michael
came from Amazon he programmed on the Kindle Fire he
also took good knowledge with him and of
course we were able to copy a lot of runtastic
one-to-one like
the Excel file for the pianoll, so to speak
and and and and and it was a bit of
a jumpstart and a few years ago I
worked again
where the app that's kind of
my Quark core competence everything
that revolves around the mobile app
we put it on a new footing again
but other than that they
have great management 200
employees now and mega
growing USA 30 people I think it
works well now okay
so it hasn’t been one of the
probably most successful digital
companies from Austria
because of course it
wasn’t represented in the media as much
as I said  Michael was with you in the
podcast you can listen to and
I would think there
will be a very nice
trip and store in the next few years and there will be
many more investments overall but how
many investments have you made exactly
I have the sum now  You always have to
differentiate between my former
co-founders that there
were four of them at Runtastic, we had about
30 investments in the startup area,
mostly very early stage. I have
another 10 to 15 myself, so I
think about 42 43 I have it today
once counted like three four
there are no longer three four got
exactly
big well uh I think who was with you
was Boom the children's bikes they are
very exciting yes that's exactly what happens
then of course there are a few others
now we're doing a rollup or where
you can develop apps yourself  the hot
Rocket Apps they were super successful
beforehand with their own app they
built the translate app and from
Großexit also been
relevant worldwide in Austria yes exactly that
translation is number one worldwide I do
n't know how big the exit was but
it was somewhere  between 50
and 100 i think more in the area
i really don't know
and the bauma now what do you do there
we build a lot of individual apps and
also buy one or the other and want to
take a subscription a super subscription that means you
get for five  euros a month or 50
euros a year a whole set of top
quality apps your vpn app your
photo editor app your scanner app your
weather app and and and that you don't
pay individually for one two three euros
but for one brand of one
subscription  That's interesting because
theoretically we've already
built it that way at runtastic. You have
a membership and then you can
use all our apps and the
guys are really good at building apps
and understand the whole equisition
game very well, okay, so it's okay to
pull out  in New York they are
that means they do
n't have any mains that's the
exciting thing they have lots of individual apps
for a wide variety of areas and
no strength
is the strongest I hope that
saying that's the authenticate
authentication app as you know it
for Google and  everywhere for the two
factor authentication everyone would
now say like why what should
you build where you earn money or
something but they have built in features
that you can transfer from one phone to the
next Apple watch
support and that works super well
but we  look at us too, of course,
we've built a radio app Zimmer
auf Radio Keywords in the USA have always been
better like um there's
all these radio apps Tuner FM and so
we're already number four in the keyword
rankings worldwide so we now have
organic  I think one so not
organic we have so organic and
Pete now half a million downloads
a year a month so
half a million a month and really
good conversions too and what is the name of the
product
apps then you can find 12 apps in there
and it  there is always the
last one that has just been launched on the iPad,
which I think will also
get a lot of love from Apple. It
's called super Notes, it's a WhatsApp where you
can draw and so there are so
many different, incredibly difficult
apps, so to speak, in one company
Management I mean most companies
have problems with their own app I
think 13 employees now 13
employees yes and of course a
bit of external development with
external developers involved but the choir looks at
what they can do very well or what we
know very well that is our
main business  you have always understood
and if you do the lean if you you
have a script for everything to
create screenshots you
somehow have your you have a playbook
how do you build apps how do you bring the store
what do you need you need the login
component yourself you do it  Tracking
itself is super complex but that's
also the belief where you
are better than others but again we
've been around for just over a year now we
also have investment so we're
investing Stefan and I
together with full sexy capital
Alexander Kudlich and
I think it can
be very, very exciting, but it's not an
incubator in that sense, it's
really a housing where a
wide variety of B2 apps come out, which
you can all use once you
've paid for what it costs  the
one-off subscription 4499 a month or 50 euros
a year so not expensive for so much what
you get relatively cheap
our bet will be that you can
convince a lot of people
that you might use one two three of the 10 12
50 apps in the future
but you are engaged there and
stay in it and therefore the lifetime value
is of course insanely high and the login the login is simply a very high okay that means you get stuck but
if you only get stuck in one app and
maybe several but the idea
is  your use case is probably
different from mine you come via the
VPN app I come via the scanner app
and then comes I know hey every year
5 new apps are top quality
why should I cancel this subscription
so to speak there is
a role model  there really is
n't anything like that there's a little part
of that that we'll also be able to buy
you could also say it's a
scooter business and we
also build products ourselves for scooters like the Amazon
siblings there are the shresio and others
you always have to think about them
from the metrics that we are looking at
right now we
are currently looking at the chance for the
first apps that you could actually buy right across
the board so we are looking at
apps that are organically going well that
can go in all directions  that's
the interesting and at the same time more
incomprehensible thing is we do
n't have a vertical where you say we're
heart and fitness or we're
productivity but we're all over the place
so if you have a good radio app is a
good scanner app good night with it well
you should already be
relevant  So there
should be a minimum of downloads, I say,
but somehow generate 100,000 downloads a year,
no, if someone walks around
and a small team of two or three
people or something and then they have 100,000
downloads, something exactly, then
it’s a bit like that
like the Amazon shops that were
recently opened that you say okay then
we would like to talk and look at each other
and look at the
metrics and the good thing is that the
map and the account have already been
transferred, which means that you used to
be OMR and  that is now somehow
transferred to me at my company, then
you can take the account there with you, it
has become a bit more flexible, everything is
generally separate, I mean,
Amazon shops are often
somehow two or three people,
business is and you say okay in the end
sold  the account, the person
then often goes out because the
new owner of the account, that's on
Youtube, too, so somehow
large Youtube accounts are simply
traded and then the
previous operator goes out and
someone new just takes over the
account for  the keyword and paid
for it a part millions here will
also pay millions logically
we are just having a look at it is
of course everything in the millions area yes
there is no other way to
tell it and maybe people will get in touch
but what are you still doing and
it is still being built up  do you
also write to others and ask
and talk to them because
you notice one thing, I thought for a long time that's okay,
I'm currently building with the apps myself,
but you can talk about that later, but I
think the exciting thing is that you say it like that
App business is kind of dead but
the app business is not dead, the
behavior has changed, but there
are always many good apps because
we get the founding team informed,
they were bought, they have
changed, so you shouldn’t
underestimate how exciting that is
Business is and where people say
now I made the app for seven years
for them a little money
but I have to maintain it I have to
maintain it and I would like to do something new
and we say hey cool
you can bring it in with us we  build the shell of
new ones all around we take a look to see if
that fits in with us
and of course we can
calculate it completely differently in terms of costs
and our idea is of course also
cross selling you use one app
we can tell you the second one
also fits well  you that would be the idea but
again we are just
over a year old or a year and a half
but it is going in a very good
direction the first metrics are showing very
well and the founders as I said I
said half a year or so if
you  keep looking they will be
good good patients one day
you are our ambassador
Austria embassies very happy very happy
open so when that happens
we are curious but I mean your
life
consists of so to speak many
app stories and there are
other ones you have right now  teased you're
building a bit again now
when you have time then you say something
completely different yes exactly we can also
talk about songs that's my
startup what I'm doing but what I'm
really doing right now my side Hassel
about a nice American
So
I also wrote my side project,
we also had really great
fitness apps back then, so we not only
had the runtastic drive and the
training app, we also had such a small
single-purpose app, but it was always
called doing push-ups
or something  and I've been doing it since I've been
training so you're me 15 16 so I'm
25 years old meanwhile 50
lying down every day 50 to get up so it
's like that there are two things when getting up and I
can only recommend that one
is to make your own bed because it doesn't matter
how  [ __ ] or sorry for the
word or how bad the day
was when you come home and the bed is
made and then that feels good to me
exactly and second is actually the
push ups push ups go everywhere
go super fast and it doesn't matter if you're
20 now  does or 50 or all at once
or three times that's just cool
and now I do more I
do it often since the app came out I
do over 100 every day but you would
n't believe push-ups do that
much so I have people who have had
herniated discs  and got
it under control by doing push-ups
so in my opinion it's
a totally underestimated exercise and many
who train know it's a cool one
now everyone says why do you need
an app for that of course you do
n't need an app to run you didn't
need an app either but  we have seen
that millions of people have been
inspired and what they
have built there now was so my claim,
in addition to what I do otherwise, in addition to
Lieder 21 and the startup and the
other investments at the weekend
and in my free time, just such a
project  but wanted your agency
called Captain they are with
us in Linz doing a great job they
did an internship for us once
and it is really good and said from
the bottom up on vacation this
summer I don’t know if my girlfriend
and friends  who said to me
why did I go to a blog like that
where an iPhone is recorded,
I said I’ll build an app
on it and then drew the wire frames
myself with a ballpoint pen,
then I thought about the concept again, and
then of course it froze  with the
agency a bit of an offer what do
you need and like every project it
got more complicated then then
okay then okay we need a leaderboard
I need country filters I would like to be
able to filter in the leaderboard who has
their Instagram account and we
bring in reality a plan and
then it was e.g. four weeks before the
launch I
only have an iPhone 13 and
I gave it to my
first friends and acquaintances to test and
then René calls me my customer
colleague says Flo the app doesn't work
it recognizes mine  lying down doesn't get the
result and he has an iPhone 14 pro
and it has the proximity sensor that we
use to detect push
ups it's kind of a new build and all of a
sudden it doesn't work like you put the
cell phone down and then you kind of do it
and normally he has
nutritional sensor so if the iPhone
lights up and you hold it to your ear
while making a call,
it switches off this proximity sensation
14 has been converted and you can
no longer see any push ups with it, now
we had to look at it and
you can open the vision kit there  access the camera
now we detect your
face Messenger and have
solved that again but that just happens along the
way and then it will be a
little since then it's still a
little time rush but then I
said okay I know I need
Japanese Chinese everyone  my contacts
in the world somewhere who will help me now
my sister knows a lot of people who
did the whole translation we
have now translated it natively to the new languages
then of course I know in the App
Store but small hack screenshot you
several languages ​​so somehow with
something again  I would think
it was very
price-sensitive, everything that means a
six-digit amount but not a high
sex position, so more in the lower
range and it is a mega
full-fledged app with registration with
liederboden with filter with planning with
dark mode light mode
so the functionality or what  the
app enables the user to be challenged,
so to speak, to
always do it in the morning because it is
measured and because it is
somehow drawn online in case of doubt
and measured while doing so,
then I have to somehow
keep a book myself if I don’t do it myself  it
all happens automatically it's a
training plan from 0 to 100% that you
can do 100 at once that would be the goal
not everyone will reach it but
then I tested it myself
underbought so three four months ago
I actually did 100 once
now I think there are fewer  um and
so the goal automatically everything with you
have all the statistics you have records you
have freaks you get badgers so
there are a lot of gamification elements
built in which is getting bigger and bigger in fitness
costs 1999 a year is called pusha 100
pusha cheap support coach can only be found
on iOS  currently in the App Store and
my idea is that several more
apps will follow this year in a
similar way, so
the same playbook will be done a few times
differently and now
continue,
we have that, that would be an option
pull-ups is in my  extended
circle so it doesn't come immediately
as if there were two other things yes
I'm not allowed to say so much yet the
decision is very precise I
think my high jump is also in
my extended area so
be careful I
still have to build up the concept  with Apple now
somehow talking about how to integrate the Apple
watch naturally, especially
on the mountain up to e.g. makes totally
senseless, so to speak,
at least lie completely on the ground on your
stomach and then do a
high jump, i.e. the combination of
push-ups and a high jump and
is a very exciting exercise  in order to also
get the circulation going so
in the shark intensity area it is
done very happily many people hate the
purpose but of course you can sell your
whole body in the end is the idea but
then you can also
sell it yes it will be one for me
Give premium membership for 19.90 a
year you get everything I
build here in the highest quality there are always
individual apps that also
share data across the board, so you will then also
see somewhere on your calendar in every app what you have in all apps
done you can set goals so
I have about 20,000 push ups is
my annual goal this year exactly and
again I have learned in my life
because I have been training since I
was 15 and I think I have fitness all the time I
said I always do
10 km  under 50 minutes must always
work 50 push-ups must always work
and if you pull your abs a bit in the summer
then it’s
always nice and now I
turned 40 this year and
it still works and my two three
tricks in life if not more  ask it
's not you don't have to
work out for hours you have to go running on an empty stomach
twice a week 30
minutes slow heart rate 140 slow
fast jogs that's a tragic the
prone changes change your body
do prone four weeks and you
're a different person and things are
enough  then it doesn't always have to
be that complex, of course,
nutrition is also part of it, but
it's not a subscription case either, so
if you find out immediately
a whole series of online coaches and
somehow people like that say man here,
come with my group and so that  it's
not it's really it's
so since that's really serious
business you can do something cool
we could create a group for example
called friends of OMR and
then everyone in the group can there is a
QR code or a link anyone can
Participate and your ranking list is
okay, but it means you have time now, do
you do it all with one
money, there is no investor yet,
the GmbH also belonged 100%, for the
first time in your life, so to speak, and exactly
and then time  see where the journey is
going my plan is im I would
also like to post everything transparently on LinkedIn
what are my learnings but what does it
cost me and what do I earn
with it just pass it on also
I don’t know myself whether it works
whether the economic  being successful
is actually a question mark my
plan would be that after 2 years I would
be positive, i.e. have earned more money than
I have spent and I am
now calculating my own working hours but
not that is planned for hopefully
conservatively hopefully
that will work a lot of interest but the
app world  one has become new
but there are 999 bad ones that was also
the motivation but written
in my little press release
have the best push-ups in the world because
I always believe if you make a product
better and even a small use
case that causes a lie-up fall then you can do it  I'll
be very successful again but
I'd like to face the challenge again in
two years. The app has been
live since Wednesday. So
I've been live for a few days
now
done
recently okay that's uncomfortable that's something
you don't understand and then on and on
at the runtastic already so I
've been painful assio too
when it comes to the product I
always went for a run in the morning with Sophia the white one
about the beeps and something
and you have to open it, I think
if you need a product someone
in the management team has to understand and
live the product and manage it every now and then
that doesn't mean every day
somehow but the basics have to
work and I'm interested in
usability a lot, too, a lot of gadgets just
because  I want to test it from the UX point of view
I sit down again similar
to you but also from the same
car brand
support ambassador in Austria
but I also like to sit down in
the Tesla to understand what they build
better how is the interface good
so yes  really why do
things work so sensibly the normal
end user doesn't think about usability
but then they understand that
it feels good it's convenient and
at runtastic those were things like that
we understood
older people need a bigger
stick button like the 19-year-old  and so and
that's all usability somewhere and that's really
good for me, so that's
somehow another apps or
products now sales from Tesla that
you've seen in the last few years with these glasses that run through the world where that's okay, that's awesome
really surprisingly good
when the world and when something
stands out then it's mostly marketing
because that's how I see it not but
clever you're obviously looking
at UX what did you notice so much you
I've been wearing the wubbable band of this
fitness bracelet for several years for
three years  now consistently number of the
month probably far too much money there
was 25 30 € this for me is totally worth it
for me in my opinion
for a fitness bracelet that was
a bit
commodity this topic Fitbit and then
xiaomi already needs the bands for
20 € and we and everyone had something
and they brought it to the first
next level but because
the software is so good they
simply built really good software,
especially for sleep quality for analysis
with podcasts that play extremely well at the same time
and so wherever I thought
it was really good UI and product
because I'm still like you can
see I already have it and
above and I really recommended it to 10 20 people,
so before I
knew it I knew that they were Corona
positive  So at least
my data showed that I
became alert second November 2020 resting heart rate
instead of 50 68
species frequency instead of 16 5 17 8 and
knew okay I didn’t
feel sick at all but you knew I must
actually have Corona did a test
somehow  10 a.m. two
ropes okay here we go and that
somehow showed in the diagnostics and
so it’s enormously exciting what’s possible there
so I’m good for so long charity
topics and so look at I’m
also there in Hamburg with Nils rain
exactly how you have invested in the meantime and I'll look today at what you
do with all the topics I think Apple is of course awesome and I
also said the Apple watch the big and game
is that everyone will be transferred
and you will ever make it
had the breakthrough further
blood sugar measurement just managed that
in the next three four five ten
years blood sugar can be measured purely optically
and I took a look,
they now have the 256 skis inside,
which means they recognize
the new percentage 99 point 5 times in a car accident
and if we come from the diagnostics
and you can then put the thing on your parents or
yourself we are already
at that age and I
know that will proactively recognize my heart attack
or maybe that will help me to
live longer or one  If
you see the illness earlier then you really have no
chance of not doing it and that's really
exciting because you can see now that
I'm also in talks with Apple about how
important the Apple watch is for
my apps too, so to speak, they want it
and that's fair  and that
also makes sense in general if you
follow the last few years, it's also
a lot of fun to pass things on, so you
were also a juror in the
Austrian version of Die Höhle
der Löwen, you took part in it for a while, it's
also because you wrote a book
and  now also then at
some point I decided to found my
own academy so that again a
separate topic tell me a
little bit about what's behind it and then
a few words about TV
you're still saying no I don't do that anymore
I did that for two and a half three years  did
n't feel like it at all maybe
only partially true you have to say to be fair
Austria is of course a tenth of
Germany and it was then
that fewer and fewer digital start-ups
came onto the show and that's
still my passion, so to speak,
and I didn't want to now  not meant to be
disrespectful at all, but invest in the
next craftsman who
invented something and such a
woman
Apps yes yes I do that
I invest in two or three startups
because especially for me makes
such a small incubator so even
they have 14 holdings right
now  met on the plane by accident
and am invested in Frank josef in
Munich, so all over the place but
what can I say back to the show it
is then of course also from the effort at some point
you shouldn't underestimate how
many days are and this follow-up
preparation I'm single sometimes
I have  no back office i do
almost everything myself what i like where if
someone has good input with virtual
assistant and in general with you do it
how can you do it well i have
n’t found the solution for me yet and
then at some point after
two and a half years  but it was
enough again only it was already it
promotes entrepreneurship in Austria in
Germany you shouldn't underestimate
it has an impact such a show the
book also has an impact and the
best thing is of course when somehow
the proud dad says the proud mum you
me  my son my daughter
bought it now too or was there something on the
show when the
14-year-old was already filming how can that be
rated now you really should
n’t underestimate it and I think what
we don’t have enough of in Austria and Germany
is simple  Entrepreneurship
and also a bit of
basic training what is the
entrepreneur who is that and it
needs more people will be a lot more solid
Meier and someone well we will invest in
the next one but I took my boys with me to
pay with the 30
investments so we are closed  fourth
now I think almost only
invested almost 20 million euros in the startups wow yes
okay that's nice yes
for some are ahead yes yes it would have been what
we do yes maybe wouldn't be
smarter then but
the remaining money would have been
invested in a lot of ETFs
or a lot in  So the fund invests in
larger funds, what did you do? I do
n't think I have a clear
idea of ​​what I did. I
tried to split it up a bit,
so as I said, we're already quite involved in the
start-ups
i always together
with my founding colleagues we
do a lot together we
believe in 20 how they drive too
invested in my opinion too many
but it's 20 years so
in germany there are or in germany
many
austrians in germany stop by
holzmachen before 6 a.m. project  aeah
yunamate visionary club uhm yes so
across the street uhm
in London at first mini capital at Red
hoverman there too but
probably in what form we are
now with the fund that is further
Speed ​​Invest 1 has expired but that
was the smallest he has quite  well
it works you can say and
you know right now the numbers are
so there are also the
ratings the 2020 and 21 and 22
inside invites them so I think we
'll learn it first but to
come back to the question that's a
Part startups, part like them, then
like everyone else, we tried a little bit of
private banking. So I was
disappointed there, or do
I have to say, because I
later learned to do the numbers myself
and we also have your
podcast  Colleagues the doppelganger guys
built their [ __ ] back then where you
could see relatively well what
you actually do ETF with less
management fee with 0 25 or so in
return over 10 20 30 years so that's
my one area now ETF is so
long by itself  times strategy as it
is private activity startups bought real estate
and then bought a bit of
houses, so to speak,
bought a shopping center one or the
other you
have to be careful now in Austria
one of my friends
did it as a song so that I
work together a lot and that’s kind of
in there  Bad Ischl in Austria in such a
beautiful place and so that's
not the huge huge sums but it
's a clean retail center just
underestimate the future of course in any
locations where you have such specialist market centers or something
or shopping centers where you can find
local suppliers in there  has the Spar or the
Rewe or something like that, of course they attract people
and then you also have the other
shops in there that's something that wo
n't die out so I'm with
you I come from first here and there and
especially in the clothes and and and
unlikely but  there are always
concepts from me, the company is called
City Outlet, so they make high-quality
clothing products, so to speak, but at
outlet prices and so these are mega
successful in Austria, they have
now been open for 14 days, so I think
you can’t do that without [ __ ], yes,
which ones you know  You there, no, I
'm not with Katrin, no, you don't know them as
well, I think Port and Dad are
different, so they are there, I have to
be in the scene so that you know them,
but there are some of them, how do
you say Rapid  recurring
funds where the third or fourth was
found is where you just like to look a little
bit right now
comes in through relationships or can't
participate and is consciously
not only technology-oriented in the
private equity cases but also
buy up the medium-sized companies and such
Things so that the sportfolio
is a bit diversified and then there
are private stocks so that's
just a gamer portfolio but I do
n't do much with stocks that was
a bit easier for the last five years
then believe me somehow yes you
understand stocks that's where you learn  now
reality which I think is also important to
me but this enormously good
to be in the red now, so to speak, and
somehow I have no idea anymore portfolio
minus 16% or something like that it
doesn’t feel more comfortable and suddenly
you learn okay it doesn’t just work by itself
and I think it's also
important to be able to experience what
you've also built,
so to speak, have often been asked by the
public to be perceived as a person who
can inspire digitally, so to speak
more out of it yes two things
we have seen at rantastic how
one grew from 100 to 150 people
we grew far too fast we
didn't cream the people so well
the teams didn't
work anymore probably the
processes and the
organizational structure  didn't
grow with him and he's an employee
coming in my colleague Thomas
kleintechnik who actually came from the
consulting area has
seen a lot himself has
had coaching training and such and he took
care of the organization with us
first of all that the good
employee  There is further development, how do
we put managers together, how do
we train managers and how do
we build teams so that teams
are high-performing? we
introduced them then, okay, objective sights
have become more and more agile, scrum
methods blablabla and somehow
everything manages that the organization
suddenly has 150  160 170 people
ran well again or noticed that's
why I can't. I was
n't able to do it as well as he and
thomas was with runtastic for a long time
and two years ago
Thomas came to me and said you Flo
you know I wanted to  always
be independent and do you also do something together with
you if you explain yes we can but
you know I somehow had 30 startups back then
and always do three things I
can always be an operational SEO startup
at the moment because I don’t have the time
but I definitely can  work operationally for a few days
use my network and when we start then
we have the advantage that you already
had a playbook a few times and
can use a few things again and
what did we do we
founded the company leaders twenty one
so twenty one because of that  because we say
we Equipment Team Swiss twenty first
centurious skills i.e. skills that you
need in the 21st century is very much about
soft skins and then we
founded the company as a couple. two of my
runtastic down colleagues are there
part-time too
Text then took care of
a small investment round so
last year in October we um
I think yes I think we have
700,000 with Angels Hansi Hansmann and
great business angels in Austria
but then there are a few
support programs in Austria I think that you do that
almost millions have now set up
and we are building what we are doing we
believe in the continuous
development of teams and people we
all know that we do
introductory training three times a year on the
event side everything is great only the
managers on Monday we come
back to the company are on the
hamster wheel  emilienpraxis full and
somehow lost everything and we are building
a software a platform where they
learn 30 to 45 minutes every week it is
structured like this academy gives you content
but short negroes with content then
we have a playground where you
have to apply things an exercise for yourself
one exercise is, for example,
write an instruction manual about
yourself who are you i'm
Philipp how can you earn a gold star with me
i like punctuality
and i like somehow but if it
runs smoothly what i don't like
somehow and that's what you do  you
your profile others can look at it
and so you learn every week
and what we see now for many
companies we work with
now we have sold the first 30
seconds and the first hundreds of
licenses so how you sat
business then see that too  which
are also the physical training for customers
companies our customers are companies from what
does a license cost per
employee per year 360 euros
so to speak 1 euro per day and we have companies
like adverity the austrian
skeleton with 300 people there we have the
executives from london  Coached New York
Austria and that's the
platform for all employees,
but we also have other customers who
are medium-sized companies or large corporations in Austria who buy it for their
hypotentials, so you can see,
by the way, the scooter is now
starting somewhere because there's a
path for our employees and managers
for both and we believe very, very
strongly that team performance
has to be optimized a lot more in the future and we
have to invest a lot more here because we're
all fighting a lack of staff, good
people often leave and we all say
people don't leave companies the leave
Bad Management and it  It is very often the
case that people leave because of bad
managers and we go in there,
but again we have
two years to go, so what is it, so to speak, does
Laa currently have erm that you
have to make a distinction because we
also do the classic  Consulting
on top of that, you make seven-figure sales,
but that's the classic way of doing
consulting business, but we learn
a lot there and in addition to
our licenses, as I said, we're
now on our first few
sub-licenses, but we've been
out on the market for four months and biobi
itself  The cycle is typically a
bit longer now we have a few
hundred licenses we want this year
I think 1250 licenses
I think somehow make our first
€ 200,000, um yeah okay
as a business thought that then
in the end of course
you name what you get financed nowadays
and  what can become great
further training
in the broadest sense in a b2b context for
resources for employees and
managers and really also how you
build teams so we
also believe through peer learning,
for example, someone leaves a book and
has experience with it that in the
company others have it too
Read participants their experiences to
really bring four groups
together because when learning the
biggest problem what you also with the
duolingo app or what they are all called
busuu and co
sorry what you have there is
learning somehow commitment goes down
after months that's why
you need more  That's why you also need your
exchange and right now with remote
working with hybrid work you can
of course also see that the cultural
aspects in the company are lost
if you haven't seen your manager for 6 months
then at some point
the loyalty also goes away then it's
easier to change companies if
but you learn together and
do things together again on a platform, we do believe
that you strengthen everything and
the analogy of my role in there is a
bit that Thomas is the captain on the
field to speak in football and
we have quite a lot  great teammates
and i'm probably a bit
on the side bench so more of a
trainer role because i'm trying to
make acquisitions for new employees for new
customers in the product
to pass on my knochau but it's someone else's
basement one of us how often product
builds the product  and yes last you so it
's quite normal for me
to break down the portfolio briefly so it's say Foxy
Fitness the new of the time Hassel
supposedly with the with the
fitness apps the push-ups in front
then it's the leader twenty one
so that that  the business for B2B
management development and
employee development then it is a
portfolio of
startups and above all attractive
so now you already have one from
Unicorn what you have for that then it is
then there are also shopping centers and
other investments so that my ball and
ball stays flat  Please no Private
banking things, for example, you were
n't really that enthusiastic, so
I didn't have that, so if you
then built up certain assets like
and that is also recognizable as it is with
you, then it's just that I
report a bank and  that they
want to help, that asset management has
n’t worked so well for you so far,
maybe also
individually, now you ca
n’t lump everyone together,
probably because maybe we
just did an experiment there
that doesn’t suit us, I
think it’s total  difference
someone wants to manage their assets and wants to
be called by a bank advisor every week or every month, that’s what
the market looks like macroeconomically and and
and this and this recommendation for action but
if you yourself have an affinity
and as I said the hair podcast and I
like doing things  yourself with my stuff
and then just
make yourself aware of the compound interest calculation there
comes a pounding effect that also the
wonder of the world as they say so beautifully then
of course it’s not exciting to just
go into a low-cost ETF
and diversify there a bit
and if you then too  a bit of
real estate, that might
not be exciting now, but I've
somehow always learned that a real estate
stays put and brings
income somewhere and there are the three
most important rules in the real estate
world, which are location location location uh
understand that you understand it now  are in a good position
and you somehow get there because
you also have networks and then
I think it's an exciting game and
at the end of the day you have to
diversify I think and
your plan for your future life
is that it
runs until you're 40  continue like this for the next few years,
or is there still some
greater purpose, I mean, many
people are also starting, so to speak, about
about yes challenges of the world apart
from economic issues and
sustainability engagement in social
issues or in ecological issues
maybe that's up-to-date  What is also
on my mind is that there
are two big projects, one I'm
going to be a dad for the first time in June.
That's actually
the biggest project I've got ahead of me
and I'm really looking forward to it because it's
just great  life is enough thank you thank you
and the second thing the way everything
is set up now you shouldn’t
underestimate investing young people in
startups and projects like that
you’re doing well too you’re promoting
a lot of things these are also topics
where it’s more sustainable  we have a
very programming school for children and
other things, I'm not quite
there yet, I'm thinking about how
financial literaces can really be
rolled out in school, how we
can do something like that, but I think you
need the focus and there
I'm not with me yet is
doing the Basel again myself now
look at the song that works
help with the other start-ups that is
still in phases where you
can already help yourself and that's how
the week feels and there will also be one  a
little bit too ball sounds too stupid now
but it may be that in five
years the focus will be
completely different did you hear the podcast with
Christian Vollmann I
heard exactly today I said
he sees himself somewhere else he feels
needed somewhere else  Excitingly also
driven by his children,
dad said what do you do, I am an entrepreneur, what does that
mean, what are you looking for, what do
you do for climate change,
well, I think you
have to come from somewhere,
and of course we have a huge one  Farm
at home I'm very I
went to agricultural school, we're
very aware of many of the issues there
and I think it's also important
to understand that you have to start doing something sooner,
but you have to start with yourself
and that's possible  a little
things loose you might tear with the
normal drinking bottle and not always
with the plastic bottle, look here and
there how can you deal with electricity and
and and and I think I
try to do a few things for myself
but they certainly don’t have
the impact yet  maybe could be again
but there is still a lot to come there is still
a bit of time otherwise you
also left out a few other half-
look at it very consciously, I
mean you are someone who is at the forefront of
the topics but we don’t
even have over  Crypto what he talked about
between our podcasts in the last few years
and
seems like he
passed it no it's not
good and bad I'm
invested in crypto now as a private
crypto investor but I
'm in a small area in a startup Conan
are called the ones in Austria who do a very
good job, they sort of
manage your portfolio for it, that means
you put money in and then there are
different portfolios, I have to
say we're doing this now, we're doing this
little one and these coins, so to speak, it was
of course a very difficult time
everyone was open too but the team does a
very good job for us want to do or
pietten in the other direction so I've
already been to the web 30 topics
have a two at a two icos and so
also participated of course quite fair and
openly lost money here too  didn't
work and you then
asked the question yourself afterwards, okay, you sometimes do things
where you really don't know much
and where your affinity is manageable
and I think I would only
participate more and in one example where
I participated is  slimewire these
are Austrians who have already
built third companies, which was very
successful, they have the brand, yes,
he has this biopia MP3 player, so where
can you download it then
bought the brand and they are building something
Web 3.0 moderately around this brand now
I invested so that's
fine I think there are three or four
investments in the crypto area I'm
also in Jam Becker's kryptophan
but of course the
numbers aren't so okay now the
next big one is half off with you um
I'm on when  but since actually
now erm nowhere in the investor area
inside
I would probably also not
know enough about the area but
among other things I know that then madness I'm
invested as before myself
capital there of course do a lot so
I'm honest then
I probably do
n't know enough about it I'm now looking
at things with jet-pd how can I
use it for myself how can you
maybe I think there will be some
companies that will
develop from it that use the technology, so to speak,
and therefore what  building something new, that
's exciting, or
maybe you know Story Clash, who also
use egg and have already used it to recognize
things in the social media area
and to find Instagram influenza and
tiktoker that might
fit a brand, so now
you can do that  always in the broadest sense you are
then invested there, but it is definitely
not my focus, to be
honest, it goes somewhere in time, uh, your
own story and so on
and I have a bit of an investment
stop for myself because you will notice
40 startups your own
projects the quality that
can deliver decreases and it's not
always the purpose that's always gone yes the
firepower is gone I think so you
mean money of course yes that is also
yes in any case I am also relatively
invested  So if the
normal bank or something would rate me
and there are five levels, I'm
actually on the way at 5.8 but that
's kind of life again, so
I find that exciting and that's a
good thing because if then they  If
the party is over then you do it by
saying no,
that means that you actually have the money what you feel, so
honestly,
yes, now you have a bit of a reserve,
I think if you can handle money
and hopefully do it well,
you should divide it up  that you
still have liquidity, but I
also have a bit of leverage there and there,
but everything to a normal extent,
but of course I couldn't make
the next huge investment right now,
but that's also good, that's why
you're in the wasp and stuff  Things
are fine because the bandages keep you up
to ten plus minus two years,
many very intelligent too, but link
to the apps because I
think about what you said
is my feeling and what is always
reflected to me is that people
just have a lot  install too few peas at all
so in the past you
somehow got to
know a new app somehow not even a week
then installed it tried it today
the frequency is totally low you have it
yourself home screen like half a
year ago or like a year ago there is
hardly anything  that's wrong yes that
was my thought too and uh our
headline we made at Rocket Apps
it also means the app
stories are broken the experience is the
app stores are broken and I think that's true
when you talk to Apple now they
say  App Store has views I do
n't even know a month or was
still 600 million that go in the apps
but my statement was
you yourself downloaded an app in the last three months
if not then please go to the
Foxy fitness store, honey, but what do
I want  say that this is a thought
that is half right and half wrong, which was
even more the case with us at the
time when the organic
growth was testing, people were actively
looking for running
for fitness for weather whatever
and now you have  you found your apps
your community earlier you
had a lot of followers very quickly he
restarted his account because
he gave away the old one and is
surprised that it is hardly growing although
he is now a well-known name and
that finally seems to me
super nice analogy in the app store and that's exactly
where you start now you have to
do marketing now USA
exquisition in the app store is a must
we at runtastic we almost never have that factor
yes we have already
spent money on facebook and such but to a
manageable extent  and had
150,000 plus organic downloads daily the
time is up that means you need to
be metric optimized but the market is
still big enough you can't
underestimate it in the
billions of smartphones out there you don't know
and people are always looking for things and
some things  disappear and there are
new things, so that's a
perception we have that the App
Store isn't there anymore, that a lot
happens then, but I'm on the road
a lot because of Rockets, through my own apps and so on,
and I'm only now seeing what's
possible again  and how many
apps are familiar with them, an app is
not allowed to tell the exact numbers, but they
actually do it with a single-
purpose app that is not that big, we
somehow make three, four million
Ebners with a small team of six
people and that's just it  it's really exciting
so the app store is the experience
is just broken but apps per se
still work well and where do
you buy the users from the
marketing app store itself or on tik
tok or where are the main three four
channels it's Apple has it  started with the
search Edge a few years ago
so very classic
search AIDS in the App Store inside
the second then of course over meters
Facebook Instagram now
super cool and works
really well in some cases tiktok is
also very exciting as the first I only know it has its
own Creator Marketplace for 2 weeks
built so similar you can
make Luca likes groups there for me I
went in and looked now I
would like to have someone who does push ups
who now says something between 20 40
is somehow fitness and has something like that in his
profile somewhere and then
you can  say inside I'm bidding for
so tiktok said okay reach in
Germany there are still
somehow 3000 influencers who
fit in there who have about reach XY
and I say now I'm offering 300
dollars for a post the son
doesn't make her exciting I have
unfortunately  no numbers yet because the app
has only been available for a few days but
I'm just getting started and we see that
with Rocket Apps too that that's extremely
important but of course you also have to use
your low ones and that's the
difficulty because Apple has it as an app
Transport tracking where he 80% think I
say no I don't allow that um
exactly that I'm tracked then
you have to build your own metrics yourself
and try to
understand yourself if I now switch a tiktok
video live what happens in
my app and there  that has actually
become the tracky partner in the meantime only
if you understand that you can of course do it
again like before that's always
the simple calculation custom
coast would otherwise be lifetimeo at best at
some point factor three in between and
scalable if that's possible then
there's a big investment like that
at least earlier but it has become more difficult
okay okay so an awful lot in it
big package but it was now
four years or more than 4 years of your lifetime let’s
see what they then, so
to speak, now we have 23 in the
next update of everyone in 27 at the latest
exactly
then  do you definitely have children
at least four but let's
see what happens that she
motivates herself to do new things again thank you very
much for your came yes very much thanks thank you Philipp so always
happy to be there and unbelievable what she
builds that is  nice too we got
to know her too grandma was something
completely different and I
walked through the office for the first time today
also in Hamburg so really hats off
congratulations good woman the festival
again soon so everything is cool
thank you very much ciao
[  Music]